III is over and now we know about a
bunch of the hot new games will be
playing over the next year or so but if
you're a PlayStation Plus subscriber and
want to know what you can play in July
for free I've got you covered and don't
forget to hit that subscribe button to
be the first to know about the PS Plus
lineup every month first up on ps4 is
until dawn which I can't personally
recommend enough it's a horror adventure
game where your choices determine which
teens survive the night it's set atop a
creepy mountain full of monsters and
killers and all sorts of dark mysteries
and I'll stop myself now because there
are other games to get to like the other
ps4 offering Telltale's Game of Thrones
which is also about making important
choices just in time for the season 7
premiere you can dive into Westeros and
interact with fan favorites like Tyrion
and Jon Snow making a name for yourself
across the Seven Kingdoms ps3 players
can get their hands on the classic
fighter Darkstalkers resurrection
starting all sorts of monsters like
werewolves and vampires and succubi
resurrection itself is a twofer one that
includes both night warriors
Darkstalkers revenge and Darkstalkers 3
also coming to ps3 is Tokyo jungle aka
that game where you have to survive as a
bunch of animals in a post-apocalyptic
Tokyo you've got 50 breeds and 80 animal
types to contend with
so beating Darwinism ain't easy and
finally the Vita is getting indie
platformer elemental most platformers
are about timing your jumps and dodging
enemies but in this case you'll have to
use the four elements to reach the end
of your journey the vedas second game is
the shoot-'em-up don't die mr. robot
thanks to cross bye you can also play
this one on ps4 and insert joke about
rami malek being and until dawn and also
playing the lead and mr. robot all of
these games will be available Tuesday
July 4th when the PSN store refreshes
you can always check out gameplay clips
and reviews for these titles over at
GameSpot too and if you want to keep up
to date with all the most popular
stories grab the official game spot now
app on iOS and Android
[Music]